hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III demo stage here at e3 2017 very
excitingly joining Peter and myself are
yin and yang from machinegames here to
talk about the kind of the big surprise
the end of the Thursday's press
conference its Wolfenstein - guys thank
you so much joining us thank you how is
the reaction VIN to the new classes it's
been very good and so far it's extremely
positive we're very happy with how
people have responded we are so happy he
has to be here and you know show and
talk about the game you know after this
a couple of years now even more it's
really good like a release to have it
out there always yes always is a good
thing for the team you know to be able
to talk about what they are working on
and people come up what are you working
on I can't say finally everyone can but
what I thought was great about the
announcement was that it was done the
very sort of tongue-in-cheek sort of
reveal like the live action with that
Lisa the pan serpent yeah um was that
where did that idea kind of come from to
sort of balance out the the very dark
sort of the dark part of the story with
this light heartedness right I mean it's
always of course in Wolfenstein has
always leaned towards the absurd and
we're sort of always embracing that
because we love that about it but a lot
of it comes from you know the Nazis have
of course conquered the world but we
haven't really delved into what happened
in America in the first game but this
game is all about that so so it's all
about how the Nazis are creating
propaganda pieces and so basically
subverting the American mindset and and
keeping the oppression going from moment
like I mean the the antagonist wealth
it's sort of secondary antagonist from
the first game is back for our angle
mm-hmm she's the main one in this one
now she's moving up the rank is was it
great to kind of have her back cuz she
was she terrified me yeah she's scary
that's also just such a phenomenal actor
Nina Freneau check her place throwing up
she's so good but yeah I mean all in
this game where for the first time we're
doing a sequel
so we've been able to build upon all of
the ideas because we always ambition
making it a trilogy you know so we
planted a lot of ideas in the first game
that we're kind of cashing in in this
game and throwing is one of those where
we set her up properly in the first one
and how do you feel about continuing to
push the darkness and the sort of the
evil that you know permeates these games
is that something you guys like really
enjoyed doing I think that's very much
in our comfort zone we've always gone
pretty dark with our games and it's very
of course super appropriate for
Wolfenstein but but but yet it is all
the time that sort of contrast of of
really dark stuff but also a lot of
levity and and crazy [ __ ] happening yeah
how do you know when you're when you've
dialed it up enough cuz like I feel like
every moment of the trailer like once it
really started going and it's like every
other scene was just like god that's so
impressive in it I just you know it
seems like there's an abundance of
creativity which must be great but also
like you probably just always wanted to
keep going right like when you hit that
ceiling and say okay maybe we shouldn't
go to correct I don't know I don't think
we really approach it that way I mean we
are fortunate enough to have a publisher
that lets us do what we want to do and I
think there's a lot of room for crazy in
this IP but but at the same time we
always wanted to feel grounded you know
so even though things are over the top
and they're they're extraordinary
they're also very domestic in a way and
very you know I wouldn't say realistic
of course but truthful or honest and
true as your approach to storytelling
change now that you're working on a
sequel and not really but it's more that
that we're able to build from our own
foundation this time around like you
like everything that we established all
of the returning characters all that
from story perspective we can just keep
building on those right because we love
our characters but but also of course
it's amazing to have the actors that we
worked with they're all coming back and
they're super enthusiastic because they
saw everything came out the last time
around
it's just amazing I think if you've been
if you finished uh Wolfenstein you might
be surprised the BJ Pascal is his back
cuz it looked pretty dicey for him at
the end Bert yeah and it is pretty dicey
in the beginning of this game or like
like yeah he's pretty broken yeah yeah
he's at death's door basically when the
game starts but so in the first game you
you took over this Nazi nuclear aircraft
carrying submarine Mavis hammer which is
the biggest submarine in the world and
that's sort of your resistance base now
for this game but at the start of the
game there's like a prologue and then
the first real gameplay level is when
the Nazis are invading the submarine and
so that whole level is played in because
BJ can't stand up it so worn out so in
that all of that is wheelchair combat
well Jack a phrase I never thought I
would I'm here that's quite nice it's
quite there's a nice symmetry to at the
beginning of Wolfenstein right because
he's been in his comer need obviously
weakened right nurse back to health
before the Nazis descend right yeah is
that a conscious thing of course I mean
we we spend so much time mapping out the
plot and and all of the how old all of
the character arcs all of that so
there's there's like nothing left to
chance really like we're really
meticulous of the scenes that we do and
a lot of it I think also the singing
talked before about you know sort of the
creativeness side of things like we look
at it we always try to see what the
scene is doing
because it has to it has to feel a
number of gameplay and you know there's
there's an exposition side to it there's
a character side to it but it's also or
are we looking forward to realizing it
like if it's if we read the scene and we
don't feel like this scene is going to
be so fun to record then we rewrite it
or we throw it out so all everything
that we record is things that we look
forward to recording to what extent do
you get catharsis from turning against
hate groups such as Nazis and the KKK
which we saw in this trailer as well I
mean there seem to be quite a bit of
tone here in terms of like [ __ ] these
guys it's an interesting word because
that's actually the theme for this story
is catharsis though so and that's not
just for the player and for BJ but it's
for all the characters in the game in
their various ways so piggybacking off
that is it not kind of because I imagine
you have to do a ton of research into
the atrocities and what I mean
ultimately until it ended up until what
the Nazis were planning and of course
the KKK very similar in what they will
do to other people is that is that not
kind of depressing to have to I'm sorry
to present and it really Jarvan yeah
well there's a lot of things that are
like that like we recently made a big
overhaul of our gore system and research
researching gore so funny they try to
explain that to IT about why I assure
you that we are on every terrorist
watchlist because like every other
Google that we do is not see something
what do you look to in terms of
inspiration uh when I was watching the
trailer it looked like one of the
characters the the sort of German
command and reminded me a lot of you
know others bastards Hans Landa but also
Friedrich Salah the sniper at the top of
the tower because you say when he was a
you know hitting on the girl and he was
very cocky and self-assured and it seems
like in your interpretation of Nazis
they all have that kind of cruelty and
hawkish okey well I think it's more
about making sure that the resistance is
or the opposition is
your own level like like it's more fun
to overcome an obstacle if they are as
smart and as as terrifying as possible
as opposed to you know turning them into
jokes or or portraying them as weaker
right so so we always and that's I
always look for every character and to
just one when me and my writing partner
told me rights for what rights what they
say and what they do it's always like
with their best interest in mind like we
always put ourselves in their shoes and
we try to make it as strong as possible
from their perspective right nothing no
I'm sorry no it's it's it's just crazy
to think about that these are you know
themes that using Nazis right like is it
I don't know it's nice to be able to
shoot them but back to your point like
it's it's such a crazy thing to have to
keep revisiting you know but so now that
you're in America you know how what is
particularly American about their
activities in the sequel how do they
sort of adopt their location to what
they do yeah we always what's in so this
game yeah it's about labor and so the
resists the plan from the point of view
of the resistance is to liberate America
and use that as a platform to liberate
the rest of the world and and to do that
you have to create alliances with other
resistance groups who are sort of
isolated and work together to ignite a
revolution I had something else to say
about your question but I forgot it what
okay well it was I saw the you know
being in America right oh yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah an algae yeah and the thing
is but more importantly from our point
of view is the cultural differences
where America is very much founded on
the idea of freedom right and Nazi
oppression is of course the opposite of
that so it's quite a big propaganda
project from the Nazi regime to try and
subvert that American mindset so a lot
of and that's that's amazingly fun to
work with because you know how they you
you get to see all of these Americanisms
but all of its kind of pervert
from a Nazi perspective right and it's
that fun Oh interesting seeing obviously
the man in the high castle has been a
book that's been around for countless
years and now to see it come into a TV
show you kind of look at it and see oh
they did it that way and we're doing it
this way because obviously that did the
show and the tea and the book are very
straight-laced all right well I mean the
core concept is the same not Nazis won
the war right but but I try to stay away
from other fiction along those lines
because I feel like we want to do our
own thing
and so that's been the approach III
haven't seen it but but what's funny
about it is that a lot of our German
actors are also involved in that show so
oh really do they do they feel strange
as a German actor sort of portraying
Nazis you know what I mean it's kind of
like it's a lot on their history yeah I
mean some some some of our actors like
when they are when they're told what the
part is about they're like no that's not
for me right so but the people that we
can star people that are really like our
cast is amazing like every every single
person that we cast is just shockingly
good and I think it's it's interesting
for them to to go in that mindset
because of course if you're German then
you have this sort of baggage right and
and and and I think for them it's also
cathartic to deal with that baggage yeah
is there other any demands like when you
bring this to the German you know
ratings boards or anything that maybe
feel different yeah I mean we sanitize
the game in Germany there are a lot of
signs and symbols that we let me
sanitize so there is a different version
that sends but on that level it's not
different in terms of the gameplay or
anything like that it's just they're
forbidden symbols that way but even
they're like they're just the story
itself changed like is it no no no no
not really never very great some part of
dialogues and words that I have to
replace of course but but the story
doesn't change so now we're in America
what kind which areas of America have
you specifically targeted where are we
going to be visiting and we're going to
be in New York
your limbs and Rossville those are the
ones you have seen in the trailer so
Akkad I'll just start yeah
yes outside New Orleans yeah so
basically in this game they've they've
turned New Orleans into a ghetto so they
they built this huge wall around it and
people in there are kind of left to fend
for themselves right and how will be
traveling around so we're still in the
in the giant submarine yeah and I only
see because of that you can target like
basically anywhere you want so the
submarine is basically the hub it is the
hub for this game and that's a very good
thing for us as well because we are you
know evolving that a bit since the last
games and now we can use the hub to to
be able to travel back to locations
you've previously been to as well so you
can continue can revisit locations to
just replay combat scenarios find
collectibles so that and for us that's a
big thing that we can like the player
can stay in the game like complete the
game for 100% within the game rather
than going out to a main menu and do it
for the chapter browser so that
replaying like you'd have to replay the
mission or you can just go back okay
let's go back University and I know him
and continue paying off then on the
different circumstances as well since
you've been there before you know this
time when you come back it might be
night it might be day it might be you
know you have done some destroying jiz
yeah you have destroyed some stuff and
and of course it's been not changed
environment so and that's it that's a
really nice thing so you're basically
the pea cafe in the game for as long as
you wanted I'm always so struck by the
weapon and like mechanical design in
your games I how big is the team behind
that like you know how much research
goes into these creation because they
did look some scene in the mount yeah we
do have a really good team that we call
the tge team the through the gun
experience team okay it's not super big
but they are extremely talented and and
of course their sole focus is that
through the gun experience and of course
that's the core element of this game so
we focus a lot on it
in Philadelphia there's that feeling the
first person the feeling of combat and
all that visceral stuff about running
around like like what really is sort of
the bread and butter of a shooter we
invested so much time and effort into
bringing that up - yeah how hard the way
you are you know able to control the
player within the environments and to
perform combat and make sure that it's
always you know super grounded and
strong that's something we work a lot
with but but it's interesting too
because we're not really like we don't
in the game is the shooter but we don't
think about it as a shooter it's much
more of an action-adventure game like an
uncharted or a Last of Us that type of
thing where it has a tremendous amount
of story and the gameplay is really
tightly intertwined with with the story
oh there's the in terms of that what we
saw in the trailer like BJ had this
incredible sort of morphing armor like a
metal arm there's where did that come
from that's something we also introduced
in the first game so but it's the same
thing there we seeded it there so and so
it's ready for us not that was the
advanced technology aspect that was yeah
I can get really deep into the lore this
might not be the four important is there
anything that you kind of wished you
could have done in the first game that
you're going to introduce into the
second game I don't know yeah I mean
there are if yeah if you have I mean a
single body yeah yeah the playful bodies
one thing and that's something as well
we talked about the fury gun team and
now you know for the first game we had
just had a view model the floating view
model but we are going back to full body
nah I'm saying going back because we did
it in Riddick in the darkness so and
just to get that more more even more
immersive and seamless experience so
that's a big thing for us and another
thing is that we allow the pain or the
freely dual wield weapons and different
combinations which is also super fun
within you know whatever we were limited
to us you will be the same type of
weapons what was the thinking behind
that limitation the first time why did
your philosophy it was just too much
work for us really it's a big big effort
that goes into it it doesn't sound that
much but it's it's a
huge amount of work in terms of
animation and dealing with the physics
of it all yeah and yes just just you
know all the different reload animation
si in them on and also you know you have
a handgun in one hand and a rifle
another and make that work together it's
a lot of work but it's also fun and not
even just you know when you're going
down space in which you which shot
counter or battle rifle is but also it
also works well when you sneak around
you can have a silenced weapon in one
hand and then you have a powerful backup
weapon in the other if you should get
detected so it's it's very rewarding and
fun and it's a very good addition for
the game it's you know a way we we up
the combat a bit one of the things I
loved about the first game is the the
different routes to your objective that
you could take has more thorpe input
into that because I was incredible I
mean like I remember infiltrating a
castle and sort of like peering behind a
thing and sneaking through grates and
taking on a commandant when he didn't
even know is that I could have come
through the door all guns blazing and
that's something that we also worked a
lot with now because we also liked it a
lot and that's something that we loved
about the first game that you could do
it alternate routes and you can approach
the combat scenarios in different pace
tiles so with this game we do that for
all the combat scenarios so they say
yeah it's yeah really fun there's a lot
of freedom in how you can approach a
combat scenario and you can do it from
different ways and our stealth is also a
little bit different from other stealth
in the sense that and if things go wrong
you can always fall back on measure
lasting right so so I'll just love that
feeling on going into a scenario trying
to be you know strategic and then if
something goes wrong and just going to
mayhem mode what was some of the
feedback from the first game that maybe
surprised you and has influenced your
your work on the sequel I don't know if
we really think about it that way but
but who the fans right nobody in office
or not I love our fans I think they're
the best fans any and a game developer
can have but but it's it's more about
like whenever we put something out it's
something that we feel really strongly
about and that we all really proud of
and I think that's kind of the approach
after hammers
creator because otherwise you're just
going into depressions whenever you hear
something negative right so so we just
tried to make sure that what we put out
there is the best possible game we could
have done but that is one of the things
that you mentioned you know with
different approaches and the combat
scenarios and that's also one of the way
one of the reasons we made sure that we
can you do that to neighbor commenting
on this game so that's one of those
things there are lot there were a lot of
Secrets in the first game uh was there
anything that you put in there that
people didn't find or didn't find until
a very long time after this is my
favorite question to ask yeah my games
been out for a while yeah but you're
always surprised how quick people find
things even though I hide them so it'll
never crack back yeah but they will more
secrets this time around I mean is that
something it's a lot oh yeah we have a
lot of that you know we are it's it's a
part of the Wolfington DNA well you know
it's finding secrets so it's it's a lot
of them yeah and now we also through the
districts we have the opportunity to be
able to go back and collect secrets that
you didn't find when when you're paying
for the narrative in terms of the other
characters who are going to commit be
coming into play so you've got obviously
PG passwords and you have I Aine who's
pregnant just lovely little surprise er
but who are the other characters who
will be meeting and sort of bringing
into this resistance the whole gang is
back so so everyone from the first game
is back in this game and then of course
as we discover new resistance groups and
you can kind of convince every
coordinate with them to join us going up
then it just grows from there right so
the submarine is not very populated in
the beginning of the game but as you
make contact with other resistance group
it gets a lot more populated and lots of
people if you're talking about them at a
later date I imagine exactly who's gonna
become an aboard well in the two of the
big gear resistance leaders are are in
the in the trailer one of them is Grace
Walker who runs a resistance group in
New York and the other one is character
called Horton